The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons License.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, Let's get
down to business.
Last day we started study
crystallography.
And we were looking
at ordered solids.
And we recognized the crystal
structure is the sum of the
combination of a Bravais
lattice, which is the way that
points are identified in
space, plus the basis.
And we saw that we could put a
variety of elements at the
corners of the Bravais
lattice.
And this is taken from the
archival notes where we see
the simple, single atoms at the
various lattice points.
And we recognized last day that
we could put clusters of
atoms and so on, and
even proteins will
crystallize in this form.
And actually, to make a point,
about five years ago, a group
of students came to my office
after the final exam, and
recognizing that I drink Fresca
during the lectures,
they came to me with this
body-centered Fresca unit cell.
So this just makes the point
that you can put anything at
the lattice point.
So there it is.
Oh, here's the point.
This is me at a conference
in Copenhagen.
This is outside the
Admiral Hotel.
And just to show you I'm always
thinking about 3.091, I
came outside--
and this is a colleague of mine
from France, Marcelle
Gaune-Escard.
How do we know she's French?
She's got a cigarette.
She's a scientist.
She's a woman.
And she smoking.
And it's fantastic.
And she's a great gal.
Anyways, so there we are out in
front of the Admiral Hotel.
And I notice these
cannon balls.
And what do you notice about
the cannon balls?
They are sitting in one of
the Bravais lattices.
So I couldn't resist having
my wife take this picture.
Because I knew that this would
come back to 3.091.
So here we are with the
individual cubic lattices
where we're going to focus.
And we started looking at the
properties of cubic lattices.
And I started working
through this table.
And we got down to nearest
neighbors, and so on, and this
relationship between
the lattice
constant and the radius.
And I just wanted to show
this last point here
about packing density.
Because it comes up
considerations of properties
of elements.
And so I wanted to go through
the packing density
calculation.
And so the way we handle the
packing density, remember
we're looking at a
unit cell here.
This is the cube that's
the repeat unit.
And it has a lattice constant
of dimension a.
And then depending on where we
put atoms, I want to show that
we've got three different
options here, simple cubic,
body-centered cubic, and
face-centered cubic.
And the last line of that slide
shows that the densest
packing of atoms-- this is hard
spheres, the cannon balls--
the densest packing is
face-centered cubic.
And I wanted to show the
derivation of that where if we
face-centered cubic where the
atoms are big enough to touch.
If we have 4 atoms at the corner
touching on the face
diagonal and then continuing
through the cell, we want to
get packing density as the ratio
of the volume occupied
by the atoms-- and here
we're modeling the
atoms as hard spheres--
divided by the volume
of the cell itself.
And so that's pretty
straightforward calculation.
We're modeling the atoms
as hard spheres.
And we saw last day that if we
take the fraction of the atom,
1/8 times 1/8, and 6 times
1/2, we have 4 atom
equivalents per unit cell.
And each of these has a volume
of 4/3 pi r cubed.
And then we divide
that by a cubed.
And then we know the
relationship between a and r.
This is 4r and that's
root 2 a.
So we can say root
2 a equals 4r.
Either eliminate a
or eliminate r.
We eventually end up with this
dimensionless group, which is
pi divided by 3 roots of 2.
And that is 74%.
And that's the densest
package.
If you go through the same
calculation for body-centered
packing, you'll find
it's 68% packing.
And for simple cubic
it's 52% packing.
That's the highest density that
you can have. So I urge
you to spend some time.
If you work the homework, you'll
work your way through
that chart.
So now I wanted to take a few
minutes and talk about
crystallographic notation.
Because we need to know this in
order to describe various
features of a cell.
So I'm going to start with a
Cartesian coordinate system
that obeys the right-hand
rule.
So we'll put down x, y and z.
And then we'll put up a unit
cell here with edge a.
So we have a on the x,
y and z coordinate.
And we know that a equals
b equals c.
That's the unit vectors here.
There's a little a here,
a little b here,
and a little c here.
These are all equal to the
lattice constant value a.
And all of the angles
are 90 degrees.
This is what defines
the cubic system.
So I'm going to put several
positions here.
So here is the origin.
And the origin we designate
as 0, 0, 0.
I'm going to put a position
up here, a.
And you just use the same
notation as you'd use
mathematics.
Only crystallographers don't
put parentheses around it.
So what I'm really teaching
is notation.
You already know the math.
So a up here is what?
It's 0 units on the x-axis.
It's 1 unit on the y-axis,
and 1 unit on a z-axis.
So that would make it 0, 1, 1.
And I'm going to put
a b out here.
B is out 1 unit on the x-axis.
It's 0 units on the y-axis.
And it looks like it's up at
about 1/2 unit on the z-axis.
So that makes 1, 0, and 1/2.
And so now what I want to do is
show you how we designate
directions and planes.
You use a slightly different
notation from what
you used to in math.
So this chart will be posted
at the website.
Move the coordinate axes so the
line passes through the
origin, define a vector from the
origin to the point on the
line, and choose the smaller
set of integers.
So let's do a simple one here.
Let's do from origin to b.
So o to b.
That's this vector here.
So how would we do that one?
Well we're already
at the origin.
So that's trivial.
o to b, so we're going from
here out to here.
And then what does it say?
It says choose the smallest set
of integers, no commas,
clear fractions.
So that's going to take
us out to 1 0 1/2.
But the crystallographers
don't like fractions.
So you're supposed to
clear the fractions.
You clear the fractions by
multiplying through.
So make that 2 0 1.
It's the same direction.
See if I came out two units
here, I'd end up
being one unit here.
So it's the same direction.
It really is the
same direction.
Don't put any commas.
And put brackets around it.
So that's the 2, 0, 1 direction,
which is o b.
And I want to do a
different one.
I'm going to go this
way, a to o.
So let's look at
that one, a o.
And what happens on a o?
Well now I'm going to
put the origin at a.
I'm going to go to
0 in the x-axis.
I'm going to go minus
1 in the z-axis, and
minus 1 in the y-axis.
So that gives me 0
minus 1 minus 1.
But see they don't use commas.
And so this looks
kind of goofy.
Because you get these
minus signs in here.
So what the crystallographers do
is they put the minus sign
on top of the number.
So this becomes 0 1
with a macron it.
If you'd studied Latin, you'd
know this thing is a macron, a
line over a vowel.
So 0 1 bar 1 bar.
And that's the direction a o.
So that's the macron acting
as the minus sign.
So that's the a o direction
And then furthermore, we
can designate families.
This is just the
0 1 bar 1 bar.
If you want to be a hipster
with crystallography,
you call this 0.
You say it's 0 1 bar 1 bar.
But if you're a nice chemistry
student, you'll say zero,
minus 1 minus 1.
No we don't do that in
3.091, 0 1 bar 1 bar.
Now suppose I wanted to describe
all of the faces,
every face.
So what I could do, is I
could say I want the
set of all face diagonals.
Well, that's a face diagonal.
But what I can do is in a
compact notation, I could
write 0 1 1 and use the carat.
This is called the carat.
So if I enclose in carats, this
means the set up all 0 1
1 type planes.
And so what that means is I can
unpack that, and write 0 1
1, 0 1 1 bar, 0 1 bar
1, et cetera.
And what I'll end up doing
is describing the
set up all face diagonals.
So if I want to talk to you
later when we're studying
x-ray diffraction, I want to
talk about face diagonals, I
don't use that word.
We're quantitative
here at MIT.
I say look at the
0 1 1 planes.
So you go face diagonals.
That's the compact notation.
If we want to look at all cell
edges, what's the cell edge?
Here's the cell edge.
This is an edge here,
isn't it?
It's right on the edge
of the cell.
So it's 0 on the
y, 0 in the z.
It's 1 in the x.
So the set of all cell
edges would be 0 0 1.
And you could write 1
0 0, that's OK too.
Or you could write 0 1 0.
That's OK.
But if you want to be a hipster
in crystallography,
put the zeroes out in front.
So the set of 0 0 1 directions
is all the cube edges.
And then lastly, if we wanted to
get all the diagonals that
starts from here and goes up,
we'll have all cell diagonals,
all, if you want to call it,
body diagonals, not face
diagonals, body diagonals.
Body diagonals is 1 1 1.
And the mathematics
imitates reality.
How many combinations
are there here?
I've got 0 1, and I've
got minus 1.
So I have 0 0 1, 0 0 1 bar,
0 1 0, 0 1 bar 0,
1 0 0, 1 bar 0.
There's 6 And how many
edges are there?
6.
Mathematics imitating reality,
what a concept.
That's great.
OK.
So that's good.
Now we want to look at planes.
Let's look at planes.
Now planes are a little
bit different.
This is basically what you know
from math with a little
bit of notation It's basically
the same thing.
Planes are quite different.
So let's go to the planes.
So you know the equation
of a plane.
It's x over a plus y over b
plus z over c equals 1.
And a b and c are the intercepts
at the x, y z axes.
Well, in order to make this
notation compatible to what we
have here for lines, a British
meteorologist by the name of
William Hallowes Miller in 1839
said let's define h, k,
and l as the reciprocals
of these intercepts.
And now we'll write the equation
of a plane as hx plus
ky plus lz equals 1.
And we'll use those values of h,
k, and l as the indicators
of a plane.
So here's an example.
So again, I've got the
right-handed rule coordinates.
And here's the plane.
And you can see that it
cuts the x-axis and a.
It cuts the y-axis at b.
And it's parallel
to the z-axis.
So if we were just to use the
old mathematics notation, and
put the a, b and c, you'd
have 1/2 here.
You'd have 1 here.
And you'd have infinity here.
And that looks goofy.
So instead what we want to do
is use the Miller indices,
which are the reciprocals.
So now the reciprocal
of 1/2 is 2.
The reciprocal of 1
trivially is 1.
And the reciprocal
of infinity is 0.
And so now you have something
that makes sense.
And you put no commas
in between.
And you put the whole thing
in parentheses.
So that's the 2 1 0 plane.
And there's a really
cool property here.
And that is, using this same
formulation I just showed you
for directions, the 2 1 0
directions-- you see 2 1 0
with square brackets,
that's a direction.
2 1 0 with parentheses
is a plane.
The 2 1 0 direction
is perpendicular
to the 2 1 0 plane.
And that's one of the advantages
of using Miller
indices notation with
the classical
notation for direction.
Here's another one.
This is 0 1 0.
This is the x, y, and the z.
So this cuts at 1, 0 1 0.
This is 0 2 0.
An 0 1 0 directions are
perpendicular to 0 1 0 plane.
0 2 0 directions are
perpendicular to 0 2 0 plane.
Oh here's 1 1 1.
That's cool.
See it cuts it at 1 1 and 1.
And 1 1 1 direction cuts
through the 1 1 1 plane
perpendicular.
This is an interesting one.
See the origin.
The plane cuts through
the origin.
Now what do you do?
What do you do?
You move the origin.
Because we don't know where the
origin of the universe is.
It's just a unit cell.
It doesn't matter.
So we move the origin up here.
And now what do we have?
We have 1 1 and minus 1.
And just as before, we put
1 with a macron over it.
That's 1 1 1 bar plane.
And there is the 1 1
1 bar direction.
It doesn't matter.
It'll always give you
perpendicular.
It's really cool.
All right.
And we can also specify
a set of planes.
So instead of using
parentheses,
we use brace brackets.
And if we use brae brackets,
we get families of planes.
So for example, we could say if
we wanted a particular face
so that the face in the xy
plane, facing the xy plane
would be 0 0 1.
Right, because it cuts the z.
So this is 0 0 1.
But what if I wanted to say in
a compact way, all faces of
the unit cell, all
of the faces.
So this is the particular
plane.
If I wanted to say all faces
I would write 0 0 1.
But I can't use any of
these containers.
So I'll use brace brackets.
So 0 0 1 in brace brackets means
the whole setup, 0 0 1,
0 0 1 bar, 0 1 0, 0 1 bar
0, 1 0 0, and 1 bar 0 0.
So there's only 6.
And there's 6 faces.
Again mathematics imitating
reality.
What a concept.
Make the math work for you.
You don't work for the math.
All right and just to make the
point about the h k l plane,
is perpendicular to the
h k l direction.
So that's good.
And the last thing I want to
show you that comes out of the
use of the Miller indices for
planes, is that another
property that we'd
like to know is
the interplanar spacing.
What's the spacing between
like planes.
So interplanar spacing, that is
to say the distance between
like planes, adjacent planes
identical index.
I'm going to write it to be
specific to say Miller index,
h k l in parentheses.
And the property that comes out
of this-- and you don't
have to derive it.
Somebody worked this out for
you about a 150 years ago--
is that the distance between
adjacent planes with the index
h k l is given by the ratio
of a, which is the lattice
constant, this is the cubed
edge, divided by the sum of
the squares of h, k, and l taken
to the power of 1/2, So
the square root of h squared
plus k squared plus l squared
divided into the lattice
constant, gives you the value
of the spacing in between.
And this is the a just
to be clear about it.
So for example, I think I've
got some cartoons up
here that show this.
So here's 0 1 0.
It's trivial.
What's the distance here?
The d 0 1 0 is just day.
How about here?
This is 0 squared, 2 squared.
0 squared, this is d over 2.
So this is a 0 2 0 plane.
But if the distance between 0
2 0 planes is 1/2 a, well,
then that's an 0 2 0 plane.
Then this is an 0 2 0 plane.
So point of fact, every 0 1
0 plane is an 0 2 0 plane.
But every 0 2 0 plane isn't
an 0 1 0 plane.
You can see that some planes
have multiple names.
Here's another one.
Look, this is the distance
between adjacent 1 1 1 planes.
It's a over root 3.
So as the index goes up, as h
k l goes up, the distance
between successive
planes goes down.
And the angle between
the planes goes up.
The easiest one is orthogonal.
OK, that's good.
That's good.
All right.
I think that's a good
place to stop.
I dread these kinds
of lessons.
And I'm sorry that the
parents ended up here
on a day like today.
But there's a little bit of
this notation and taxonomy
that they have to know.
And so we suffer through it.
And then we get on
to the meat.
Now we're ready for some meat.
Now that we can describe crystal
structure, we're ready
for physical measurement
of crystal structure.
So what I want to start today
is the characterization of
crystal structure by x-rays.
How do we measure?
How do we know that
gold is fcc.
We use x-rays.
So today what I want to do is
start as I always do on new
unit with history lesson.
We'll start with the discovery
of x-rays.
And we'll get into the
underlying physics.
And the next day we'll look at
applications including x-ray
diffraction.
So first of all, what
are x-rays?
They're a form of
electromagnetic radiation.
And they have the property
of that.
They have very short
wavelength.
How short?
It's on the order of about
angstroms. So strictly
speaking, it goes from about
1/100 to 100 angstroms. So
centered at about 1 angstrom is
the center of the x region
of the spectrum.
And because they're a form of
electromagnetic radiation,
their energy is given by these
equations, hu equals hc over
lambda or hc u bar.
Those equations that you've seen
over and over again apply
for the energy of an x-ray,
because an x-ray is identical
to a photon of wavelength
somewhere down at this level.
Why do we care about this?
Because this is atomic
dimensions.
If I want to measure the
dimension of the human hair, I
don't use a yard stick.
I use something that is of
the human hair dimension.
If we want to get into the
characterization of atomic
structure, we need a measurement
tool that is on
the order of that blank scale.
And that's why we're going
to use x-rays.
Now other property, I said very,
very short wavelength.
But because of this inverse
relationship between
wavelength and energy, I want
to draw attention to these
superbly high value of energy.
So let's plug in the energy for
lambda equals 1 angstrom.
When lambda equals 1 angstrom,
we end up with 12,400 electron
volts per photon.
Now what's that mean, just
to put it in perspective?
Look up here at the
table I've shown.
We know the ionization energy,
the lone electron in hydrogen
is 13.6 electron volts,
which is 14 to
2 significant figures.
And then we go to helium.
You pull these off the
periodic table.
This is the first ionization
energy.
And they're down around
somewhere
about 10 electron volts.
Look at.
This is 12,400.
So let's go down to the
1 electron atom.
So this is helium plus.
This is lithium 2 plus.
And we see a set of numbers here
that follow this sequence
1 4 9 16, which is nothing more
than the sequence you
would expect for a series of 1
electron atoms. It's K, which
is 13.6 times the square of z/
So z here is 2, z here is 3, z
here is 4, and so on.
But even so, this is the last
electron of nitrogen.
The most tightly bound electron
of nitrogen, 668
electron volts.
That's a huge amount
of energy.
But that pales in comparison
to 12,400 electron volts.
So this is clearly ionizing
radiation writ large.
What do I mean by ionizing
radiation?
It has the capacity to
ionize everything.
Every electron will
be blown away.
This is called knocking
the stuffing out of
the electron structure.
So that's what we're
dealing with.
So now let's go to the
origin of x-rays.
So how did we discover x-rays?
Well, it was a dark and stormy
night, not unlike the weather
today, apropos of the lesson.
It was November 8, 1895.
And it was at the home and
laboratory of a professor.
Of course it's a professor,
Professor Wilhelm Roentgen.
And he was a professor of
physics at the University of
Wurzburg in Bavaria, now
part of Germany.
And he was doing research, as
many people were in the 1890s,
on the properties of gas
discharge tubes.
He was studying gas
And he had a special interest
in gas discharge tubes.
Remember Lorentz?
He like to put the gas
discharge tubes
in a magnetic field.
Stark liked the put them
in an electric field.
And what was Roentgen's
pet project?
Roentgen loved high voltage.
He loved high voltage
an low pressure.
He was focused high voltage,
low pressure, near vacuum.
And so let's have a drawing
of what he used.
And here's an image of the
museum that is literally in
the house that was
occupied by him.
So the apparatus is sitting
right there on the table.
And here's the heart
of the apparatus.
I'm going to go to a fresh board
because I need a little
extra room here.
So we know what the gas
discharge tube looks like.
It's a glass tube, sealed.
And we've got feedthroughs for
electrodes at both ends.
And this goes down to
a power supply.
And the power supply
that he used was
batteries of chromic acid.
And they were open beakers.
And they were down in the
basement two floors below.
And he had wires going
from the basement up
to the second floor.
And he was able to generate
about 20 volts.
So he had a number of
these in series.
Because this is roughly
a 1-volt system.
So round numbers, you got
about two dozen of these
things in series.
And I'm going to write
here, in the cellar.
Now how did he get
the high voltage?
He put in here something that we
wouldn't recognize today as
an inductor.
He called it a choke coil.
And what the choke coil did, is
it would charge up until it
got to 35,000 volts.
When it got to 35,000 volts, it
would discharge and send a
current at 35,000 volts
to the cathode here.
And with 35,000 volts, the
cathode would send electrons
boiling off the cathode, heading
towards the anode with
the kinetic energy associated
with 35,000 volts.
And this discharged at about
eight times a second.
So I'm going to write
8 hertz here.
So eight times a second this
thing, bam, bam, bam, bam.
And the electrons go
firing off here.
And this to make sure he had
really low pressure, he had
the cell open actually.
And this went to
a vacuum pump.
He had almost no gas
molecules in here.
Now, the way he did the
experiment is, he'd set this
thing up, started it going,
and this was after dinner.
So on a Friday night after
dinner, he was upstairs.
And he wanted to measure
emissions here.
And so what he had, you either
get graduate students to sit
there and you exploit their
labor, or what you do is you
put up a detector here
which was a screen.
So this is either a sheet of
paper or a sheet of cloth.
So we call this a screen.
And so you're going
to look here.
All right you're looking at
this, seeing what's coming out
of this gas discharge tube.
And it was a screen up
paper or fabric.
And it had been painted with a
chemical that would glow if it
were struck by a particle, or by
a photon of a given energy.
And they used in this case,
coated with the chemical
barium platinocyanide, so
cyanide four times.
So you make an aqueous
paste of this stuff.
And you gob it on
to the screen.
And when the screen is hit
by something, it sparks.
And the latin word for
spark is scintilla.
Have you ever heard of someone
being described as a
scintillating conversationalist?
It means they are a sparkling
conversationalist. So this is
called a scintillation screen,
a scintillation screen.
And so presumably, every
time there's an
event, the screen glows.
And so Roentgen starts
the experiment.
And it's raining outside.
There's thunder.
There's lightning.
There's a street light as
you can see right there.
There's windows.
And the thing is glowing.
And he really can't detect
what's going on here.
So he decides to
cover the tube.
So he puts a wooden box around
the gas discharge tube.
So now the gas discharge tube
is enclosed in a box.
And he continues
the experiment.
And what he sees is glowing on
this scintillation screen.
The scintillation screen is
glowing even though the gas
discharge tube is in a box.
There was another observation
he made.
The student earlier in the
day, who had painted the
screen with the barium
platinocyanide.
I guess he was practicing
his calligraphy.
And he left a paper towel on
the edge of the bench.
And he painted the letter
A on the paper towel.
And the paper towel was glowing
with the letter A.
And this thing is enclosed
in a box.
So he's saying what's
going on here.
So he decides that there's some
kind of an interaction
between the screen and something
going on in here.
So the first thing he does is
he says, well maybe it's
electromagnetic.
Maybe it's charged particles.
So he takes a magnet.
And he moves a magnet around.
And nothing changes.
He kills the power to the
gas discharge tube.
Everything stops.
So it's definitely inspired by
35,000 volts of energy going
into the tube.
So then he says, OK I'll take
a piece of black paper.
And he puts the black
paper in between.
And the screen continues
to glow.
So then he takes a book.
And he puts the book in front.
And he sees the shadow
of the book.
And he's standing
here like this.
He sees the shadow
of the book.
And he can see the shadow of
the bones of his hand.
So he says, you know I don't
think it's particles.
I think it's radiation.
And maybe it's something like
that radiation that Hertz has
been talking about.
It's some kind of radiation.
But I don't know exactly
what it is.
It's mysterious.
And x is the letter
of mystery.
I'm going to call
it x-radiation.
So he's discovered this
mysterious form of radiation.
Does he rush to publish?
No.
He's not going to risk his
scientific career by
announcing that he's discovered
a form of radiation
that can see inside
the human body.
That would be professional
suicide.
So he continues to repeat the
experiments through November
and December of 1895.
And in January of 1896,
he finally publishers.
And it takes the
world by storm.
By the way, how did he
record this stuff?
He used photographic plates.
And he stored the photographic
plates in his lab in a wooden
file cabinet.
And so many of the plates were
fogged even before he got them
to the experiment.
Because of the x-ray,
they were going
everywhere in the lab.
And he was working there
the whole time.
So what happens?
What's the world's reaction?
January 16, 1896, New York Times
reports radiation that
can see through matter and peer
inside the human body.
Peer inside the human
body, you say.
Well, why is that?
What's the big deal?
Well, in London, immediately
there was a market response.
A manufacturer claimed to be a
purveyor of x-ray proof lady's
undergarments.
I mean if you can see inside
the human body,
it's Victorian England.
How modest can you be?
This is a calamity.
In France, of course, they don't
care about such things.
So they had a different
response.
Remember this is where Daguerre
invented halide
photography.
So there it's very deep.
It's very existential.
Somebody claimed that with
x-rays he could irradiate and
get a picture of
the human soul.
How French.
But I'm sorry to say
it, the wackiest
comes from guess where?
The United States.
No lesser an institution than
the New York City College of
Physicians and Surgeons.
They proposed to use x-rays to
project drawings from text
books of anatomy onto the brains
of students thereby
creating, and I quote, an
enduring impression.
In Iowa, we plumb new depths.
There was a group out there
claiming that they could turn
copper pennies into gold.
So this was the response.
But the thing that makes it so
fantastic is we take it for
granted that if I want to
exercise power and exert a
force on that can, I don't
necessarily have to make
physical contact with it.
We accept this as given that
you an either have direct
mechanical contact, or indirect
contact, magnetics,
what have you.
But in 1896, this
wasn't given.
So the notion that I could exert
a force on something
from a distance was
very fresh.
It wasn't so easy.
But there were benefits of
the x-radiation already
in middle of 1896.
There was a seamstress who
had a broken needle in an
industrial accident in Scotland
buried into her hand.
This is trivial.
Look, all you need is low
pressure in a gas tube, and
you can set this up
in high school.
It's nothing.
People had this set up
in dentist offices.
It's nothing.
So this surgeon was able to find
where the needle was, and
then use precision to go in and
take the needle out of the
injured person's hand.
In eighteen 1899 they were
already using radiation in
treatment of cancer.
So what is the relevant
physics?
what's the relevant
physics here?
Let's look at the relevant
physics.
Well, when we're talking about
35,000 volts, and we're
talking about energies in the
vicinity of tens of thousands
of electron volts, you know
that this can't come from
emission from an excited
electron in a gas molecule.
The gas binding energies are
way lower than that.
This must come from the solid.
The electron leaves the
cathode, and it
crashes into the anode.
Here's the smoking gun.
There's something going on here
when the electron crashes
into the anode and then gives
rise to the radiation.
So let's look inside
the anode.
So what's the energy
level diagram?
Let's say the anode
is made of copper.
So what's the energy level
diagram look like?
So we know up here we're going
to have energy is 0.
And the energy quantum
state is infinity.
Down here is the ground state.
And the energy is the
ground state energy.
And we know this is
up in the tens of
thousands of electron volts.
And then up here there's
an E2 for state 2.
And up here is an
E3, energy 3.
Then maybe an E4 for energy
4, et cetera.
And I'm going to write
not to scale.
This is just to give
you a sense.
And so the ballistic electron
with, in this case, 35,000
volts of energy, comes crashing
in to the anode.
And this is one of these
mixed metaphors.
So this is a Cartesian drawing
of an electron.
All right?
This is the incident electron.
And its energy is given by the
charge on the electron, which
is E, and the plate voltage,
which is 35,000.
So it's got 35,000 electron
volts, which
turns into 1/2 mv squared.
It goes crashing into
this thing.
And it's got enough energy
it can kick out top level
electrons, mid-level electrons,
and in the extreme,
it an eject ground state
electrons in 1s.
By the way, the spectroscopists,
they don't
like numbers.
Remember, this is K.
This is L.
This is M.
This is N.
So we can eject K
shell electrons.
What happens if we create
a vacancy down here?
all?
Of these electrons above
are unstable.
If its copper, there's
29 of them.
Now there's 28 with a vacancy.
And they fall down.
And when they fall down from
N equals 2 to N equals 1,
there's a photon emitted.
And that photon emission is in
the x region of the spectrum.
But we don't just get
one wavelength.
We get a plurality
of wavelengths.
n equals 2 to n equals
1, we get a photon.
There's a possibility to go for
n equals 3 to n equals 1.
We'll get a photon of even
higher energy or a lower
wavelength.
Well, heck, if you've got enough
energy to kick out an
electron from n equals 1, you've
certainly got enough
energy to kick out an electron
from n equals 2.
So you can get a cascade from
3 to 2, which gives us a
photon, or from 4 to 2, which
gives us a photon.
Can you see that you're going to
get an entire set of lines?
We're going to label them
because we don't
have a single line.
So what do we label them?
We label them on the basis of
the destination shell and how
far they traveled.
So this line here is known
as a K alpha line.
Why is it a K?
Because that's the nf.
That's the n number of
the final state.
And why is it alpha?
Because the delta n equals 1.
It came from 1 shell away.
What's this one?
It's gotta be a K
line, because we
ended at n equals 1.
But the delta is 2.
It went from n equals
3 to n equals 1.
So this is called K beta.
So there's a K beta line
and a K alpha line.
This ends at n equals 2, which
the spectroscopists call L.
So we call this L.
Delta is 1 L alpha.
This is L, but delta is 2.
So this is L beta.
And what I can do, is I can plot
all of this on a curve
showing the spectrum of this
particular element.
And what do I expect to see?
I expect to see a spectrum that
plots intensity versus
some energy coordinate.
It could be wavelength in this
direction, which means that
energy increases in
that direction.
And which has the
highest energy?
The highest energy up here
is K beta, n equals
3 to n equals 1.
So there's K beta.
And then close to
it is K alpha.
And why do I put the
K alpha line higher
than the K beta line?
I don't know what the relative
amounts should be.
But I suspect that if there's
a vacancy, it's
like musical chairs.
If there's a vacancy in n equals
1, and an electron only
has to go from n equals 2 versus
n equals 3, the chances
are the journey from n equals 2
to N equals 1 is easier, and
therefore more frequent than the
journey from n equals 3,
even though n equals 3 to
1 is greater energy.
But 2 to 1 is more likely.
And intensity reflects
frequency.
The wavelength reflects
the energy.
And then over here is
L alpha L beta.
Now there's one more
piece here.
The precise value here is
determined by the identity of
the element in the anode.
If it's copper--
and I had to do this
as a junior at the
University of Toronto.
I spent a whole year doing
x-ray crystallography.
And I will know on my death bed
the wavelength of copper K
alpha radiation is to five
significant figures, 1.5418
angstroms.
Now if someone had fallen asleep
in this lecture and
open their eyes right now, and
looked at the wavelength of
this line as 1.5418 angstroms.
And I erase the letters Cu.
You take one look at that,
and you say copper.
Because only copper has a K
alpha wavelength of 1.5418,
which means I can use x-ray
analysis to determine the
identity of a unknown
specimen.
And furthermore it's additive.
So if I had a brass, which is
copper and zinc, the zinc K
alpha line is over here.
And I will have both lines.
And the relative intensities
of the lines are related to
the relative concentrations of
the copper in zinc. So now I
have a tool for chemical
analysis.
All of this from going upstairs
after dinner and
horsing around with the
gas discharge tube.
OK, so we're going to end
the formal lesson here.
But we have a few
more minutes.
So everybody is instructed to
not make a lot of noise and
just sit quietly.
So let's take a look.
This is an image.
This is an image of Bertha.
This is Roentgen's wife.
This is her hand.
He invited her into the lab.
And she stood for a full 15
minutes in front of this tube.
And in that 15 minutes, got a
lifetime's worth of radiation.
But what we're looking at here,
and what I'm going to
point out to you in the last
several minutes here, Roentgen
was a prissy physicist,
a really prissy guy.
And he was German, which meant
that the German academics had
no contact with industry
whatsoever.
On the night of November 8,
1895, he invented three modern
technologies.
This is Bertha's hand.
It represents the birth of
medical radiography.
Is there anybody in this
auditorium who has never had
an x-ray, a dental
or body x-ray?
It's very rare.
We see them all the time.
We use them all the time.
This morning I had one taken
about 9:10, right here.
And I'm OK.
So that's radiography,
medical radiography.
Roentgen had a balance
in his laboratory.
The justice, and she's got
the torsion balance.
So you put the unknown on one
side, and then you put weights
that are calibrated.
These are made of brass.
And they're in a wooden box.
And so Roentgen has already
covered the tube
with a wooden box.
And so he took the emission from
this, and he radiating
his box of weights.
And what he see?
He saw dark regions where
the weights were.
Because metals have a different
electron density,
because they've got a greater
atom density than wood.
Wood is a more open structure.
And so by contrast, he could
see inside the box.
This is the basis for
airport security.
Roentgen had a gun.
He was not holding up
convenience stores.
He was a hunter.
He went into the woods.
And he x-rayed the gun.
Now why did he x-ray the gun?
Now the gun is made of steel.
But deep inside the steel,
there could be a flaw.
There could be a crack.
There could be a blowhole.
The surface of the steel
looks beautiful.
But inside is a crack.
And that crack could lead to
failure under pressure.
So Roentgen irradiates.
And we already know from this
that different electron
densities give different
shading, which means if there
were a crack right here,
you might see it in the
radiograph.
And this we use for
certification of pressure
vessels today.
Certain pressure vessels that
have to be welded, have a
specification that requires that
every inch of the weld be
inspected by radiation, to be
certain that there are no
cracks deep inside the weld that
under high pressure could
open up, have an explosion, and
cause injury, or in the
worst case, death.
So what's the outcome
of it all?
In 1901 when the Nobel Prizes
were offered for the first
time, Roentgen by unanimous
vote of the selection
committee was the first
recipient of the Nobel Prize
in Physics.
So on that occasion, he was
invited to come from Wurzburg
and to deliver a lecture
in Stockholm.
I've been to the place, it's
a spectacular hall, gilded,
beautiful champagne reception,
elegant dinner.
And he gives a lecture.
And what's his lecture on?
The discovery of x-rays.
He received a huge amount
of money at the
time in prize money.
And he returned to Wurzburg
What did he do
with the prize money?
he?
Donated it to the University
to be used for scholarships
for students studying physics.
And to this day, students
who study physics at the
University of Wurzburg are
beneficiaries of the
generosity of the first winner
of the Nobel Prize in Physics.
Such was his humanity.
I hope you have a
great weekend.
We'll see the students
back here on Monday.